I'm here to salute Angela Lansbury and
also to thank the Academy's Board of
Governors her making what I think is one
of the best decisions they've ever made
it was in August of 1943 exactly seventy
years ago that filming began at MGM on
Gaslight Angela Lansbury aged 17 about
tweet 18 stepped in front of a movie
camera for the very first time and she's
been adding class new talent beauty and
intelligence to the world of movies ever
since filming Gaslight was a defining
time for her in many ways one of the
most important being that even though
she was a beginner the moment she
stepped on that soundstage the film star
Ingrid Bergman and director George Cukor
treated her not as a newcomer who had
never been in a movie before but as an
equal a professional and that's
something that Angela says gave her
enormous confidence set her on a path
that served her well ever since after
that came a wide variety of roles she
was a tough saloon to see in American
West then she would be a middle-aged
British wife of Walter Pidgeon she was
Margaret O'Brien's schoolteacher in New
York's Hell's Kitchen and she was a rich
and powerful Washington DC power broker
helping to get Spencer Tracy elected
president well meanwhile I'm going to
movies in my little hometown of Colfax
Washington and I'm sitting there
thinking my god what a career she's got
she's got the ideal career I thought
she's wonderful she's attractive and you
never know how she's gonna where she's
gonna show up what she's gonna play what
kind of parts she's gonna do I thought
this is a perfect career what I didn't
know until later was that she wasn't all
that keen about the way of that movie
career was going she wanted more
significant roles understandable she
wanted Meteor parts to play but she
continued on surviving and more than
that making every film she was in look
better and be infinitely more
interesting and which he did get apart
with more meat on its bones like in
mentoring candidate all fall down she
would deliver a punch to the senses that
stunned us all
her record in the theater and television
is remarkable but for those of us with a
particular passion for movies we thank
you Academy members and Board of
Governors for honoring this wonderful
magnificent career may not have quite
satisfied you Angela not yet anyway but
it certainly satisfied us and meanwhile
the members of the Academy have been
paying attention certainly marveling at
your talent your versatility and the
work you do so seamlessly and so well
it's with the greatest pleasure that I
also get to thank you for all the
talented actors and directors and
technicians and crew members that you've
worked with and treated the way Ingrid
Bergman and George Cukor treated you
from day one on the set of Gaslight does
make a world a difference so dear Angie
when it comes to art of acting and
survival and dedication to one's craft
nobody deserves this Golden Boy more
than you know it's inscribed if I can
read it here a to Angela Lansbury an
icon who has created some of cinema's
most memorable characters inspiring
generations of actors miss Lansbury here
is your Academy Award at last